>> Hello.
>> Amy Stolls: Hello,
and welcome to the Poetry
and Prose Stage which
has been supported
by the National Endowment
for the Arts,
the NEA since the festival began
and I'm glad to be able to say
that we're continuing
our support.
My name is Amy Stolls and I
direct the Literature Program
at the National Endowment
for the Arts.
[ Applause ]
That was the total
plan right there.
We celebrate literature as an
art and an essential reflection
of our nation's rich diversity
of voices and we do this
by helping writers and
translators create work
and connect with
audiences through publishers
and other literary organizations
and programs like this festival.
So, we're really excited to
have, I'm particularly excited
because I'm such a big fan
of the three and I want
to call you poets,
but then also writers
and they'll talk about that.
This is a conversation we've
titled Poets Writing Prose
and we're going to hopefully
unpack that title for you
as we discuss and maybe
theorize, reassociate,
tell stories, about what exactly
we mean by poetry and prose
and how we individually
and collectively approach
the writing and reading
and subject matter of
those genres, so I'm going
to briefly introduce each
of our distinguished guests.
So, I think maybe hold
your applause until we get
to the end then we'll really
give them huge applause
and then we're going to,
well it needs to be organic,
but I imagine that we'll chat
and then each of them will read
for a bit then we'll
chat some more
and then we'll entertain
questions
from the audience, okay.
So, let's see, Patrick
Rosal is the author
of four full-length
poetry collections.
His latest book "Brooklyn
Antediluvian",
I feel like I'm going to do
do-do-do-do-do as you go down
and look for the books in
the bookstore; is the author
of "Brooklyn Antediluvian",
was published in 2016
and won the Academy of American
Poets Martial Poetry Prize
and was a finalist for the
Kingsley Tufts Award for poetry.
His collections have been
honored with the Association
of the Asian-American
Studies Book Award,
the Global Filipino
Literary Award,
and the Asian-American Writers
Workshop Members Choice Award.
He has received a Guggenheim
Fellowship, a Fulbright,
and an NEA Creative
Writing Fellowship in Prose,
and his essays and reviews
have appeared in a wide variety
of distinguished publications
and he's taught and presented
in many different
places and venues
around the country and abroad.
Currently, he calls
Philadelphia home,
teaches at the M.F.A. Program
at Rutgers University in Camden,
although this year now you're
going to be at Princeton, right?
And I just found out last night
that also you are a
jazz musician, right?
Playing instrument
with drums as well?
>> Patrick Rosal: Piano, guitar
and some [inaudible], yeah.
>> Amy Stolls: Camille Dungy.
Camille is the author of
four collections of poetry.
Her most recent and
I'm going to show this,
is "Trophic Cascade"
published in 2017.
It won the Colorado
Book Award, in fact,
her collections have won
and/or been nominated
for numerous awards.
Also, in 2017, Norton
published her debut collection
of personal essays, "Guidebook
to Relative Strangers;
Journeys into Race,
Motherhood, and History"
which was a finalist for
the National Book Critics
Circle Award.
She's an editor too, has edited
several anthologies including
"Black Nature; Four Centuries
of African-American Nature
Poetry" published in 2009,
and she's received two Creative
Fellowships from the NEA;
one in poetry and one in Prose.
I should say that Patrick
got his in Prose as well.
I'll explain that in a minute.
And she comes to use
from Fort Collins,
Colorado where she teaches
at Colorado State University.
What was that?
>> Patricia Lockwood:
I didn't know that,
my husband is from Fort Collins.
>> Amy Stolls: Oh.
Wow.
>> Camille T. Dungy:
Conversation piece.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
Restore [brief laughter].
>> Amy Stolls: Well, you know
I have to say I also just found
out that Patrick's
dad is an ex-priest.
>> Patricia Lockwood: What?!
>> Patrick Rosal: Yeah.
>> Amy Stolls: Okay, wait, wait.
So, this considered; this
is Patricia Lockwood.
Patricia is the author of two
critically acclaimed collections
of poetry; "Balloon Pop Outlaw
Black" published in 2012
and her most recent
collection is
"Motherland Fatherland
Homelandsexuals" published
by Penguin in 2014.
It was named a best book of the
year by numerous publications
as was the memoire she published
in 2017 called "Priestdaddy"
which was among the New York
Times book reviews 10 best books
of 2017, it was an Amazon
Best Book of the Month
and was a finalist
for the Kirkus Prize.
It was on the Best
of the Year list put
out by the Washington Post, the
Chicago Tribune, The New Yorker,
and the PR Publishes
Weekly on and on.
>> Patricia Lockwood: You should
say I didn't win any actual
awards [multiple speakers].
>> Amy Stolls: Oh, sweetie
I would give you an award.
>> Patricia Lockwood: Thank you.
>> Amy Stolls: Patricia.
I'm going to get right on that?
It's also worth noting
that Tricia's writing is
hugely popular on social media
and I'm saying that because
I think we'll probably talk
about that.
She has more than 71,000
followers on Twitter,
the Atlantic included two,
I believe of Tricia's tweets
on its list of the
best tweets of all time
where she was the only
author included twice.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
I didn't know that.
>> Amy Stolls: It's
true though [laughter].
And you have, are
you in Georgia?
>> Patricia Lockwood: I
am in Georgia now, yeah.
>> Amy Stolls: It's
quite the place.
Welcome to D.C. everyone.
Okay, now you can applaud.
[ Applause ]
Okay, I just; I'm going to say
one more thing then I'm going
to really back off
and let you talk.
Let me give you a
little background
about why we're doing
this session,
and that is because it has to do
with our Fellowship
Program at the NEA.
We give out fellowships
in creative writing,
but because we get
so many applications
and we have only one person
on the staff pretty much doing
this, we had to split them
to per year, so one year
you can apply in poetry,
the other year you can apply
in prose and that means
and that means fiction
or creative nonfiction
and each year we get about 1800
applications and we're able
to give out roughly about 35
to 40 fellowships
$25,000 fellowships.
Well, we gave out 36 fellowships
in 2018 and we noticed
that a large percentage of
the award winners in prose won
for their creative nonfiction,
but they actually
called themselves poets
and where mostly known as poets,
and we were thinking
"Wow, what happened?"
They came over to prose.
It's like an infiltration
of prose for the poets
and it gave us this idea to
start talking about these genres
and so my first question I
suppose that I would ask you is,
and I ask this of
you answered this
through a blog post earlier,
which is, you know, do you see
or is it fair to say that
you are poet writing prose
or do you see yourself as
a writer and, you know,
the deeper question is
really if this is, you know,
here's poetry, here's prose,
are they that distinct to you
or do they kind of, you know?
I'm going to stop with
hand gestures sitting next
to you Tricia because I feel
like that might get, yeah.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
We'll do that one again.
>> Amy Stolls: Yeah.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
That's something.
>> Amy Stolls: Yeah.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
I know it's something.
>> Amy Stolls: Yeah.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
Let me think.
>> Patrick Rosal: Yeah, I it.
I have to say that my, the whole
idea of sort of the separation
of genres is a little
bit confusing to me
for a number of reasons.
One, because when I got to know
the writing of the Philippines
where my parents are from, what
I realized very quickly was
that writers were writers
and they wrote everything.
They wrote novels, they wrote
poems, they were journalists,
they were speech
writers for politicians
and so this whole sort of
market division between,
between genres is not universal.
It's actually an invention.
And the other reason why it's a
little bit confounding to me is
that I came to books
late in life.
I came to books in my 20s, I'm
a college flunky twice over
and so my original
love was music.
I wanted to be a
composer and a musician.
I think of all of writing as
an extension really of music.
So, when we're talking about
a kind of a blurring or genre,
I think that my own sort of
blurring happens across arts.
That means performance,
the means theater,
that means [foreign words
spoken], and that means so many
of the kinds of musical
and artmaking traditions
that we have in the
United States.
So, it always feels funny to be
kind of, I'm also an academic
and to be in a department and
a discipline that is, you know,
has very specific boundaries,
it's really just kind
of an invention for
me and I navigate it
but it doesn't feel very true to
the way that I just make stuff
and the real enjoyment
of making stuff which is
across artmaking practices.
>> Patricia Lockwood: I have
kind of a; ooh I'm sorry.
>> Camille T. Dungy:
No, you can go.
>> Patricia Lockwood: I
have; do we think it's
like a whole different
from the romantics
because it's a true thing
in the United States I think
or in the West with
like novelists
as well considering themselves
poets versus [inaudible]
and I think that's true like
a lot of English novelists,
a lot of American novelists.
So, I wonder if holding
that closer to like the core
of identity is like a
leftover romantic ideal.
>> Camille T. Dungy: The core,
holding that I'm just a writer.
>> Patricia Lockwood: A
poet first and foremost.
No. No the opposite.
That thing where it's
like you'll read people
who have written
like splendid novels
and their poetry is
absolutely terrible and they're
like I still consider myself
a poet first and foremost
and they hold it their core
in almost a romantic way.
So, I wonder about
that a little bit
because I feel more as you do.
>> Camille T. Dungy: I think
I have thought about it
as a question of marketing and
where you, where you're going
to place that book in the
library or the bookstore more
than I have thought about
it as a romantic holdover
or something like that.
And I think as a writer
of color, part of why,
part of the space for my
resistance to that segregation
of various modes of writing
has to do with the fact
that Black writers are
so frequently separated
anyway, right?
They, like I remember going to
look for Rita Dove's newest book
when she was the Poet Laureate
of the United States of America
and she published a new book
and I went to go find her
in the bookstore and I couldn't
find her in the poetry section.
And I was informed that she was
in African-American literature
which is true about Rita Dove,
but she was the Poet Laureate
of the United States, so maybe
in U.S. literature
she could have been.
And that kind of sense
of categorizing her based
on one aspect of
her presentation,
I think so many writers that I
grew up admiring wrote all kinds
of things, Alice Walker.
I remember the books of Alice
Walker were all over the house
when I was growing up.
She was a poet.
She was an essayist.
She was a novelist, right.
She's a writer that she wrote
what she needed to write
and I think I came into writing
thinking I'll write the thing
in the mode it needs to be
written for that purpose
and the world is going to do
with it what it's going to do.
Like it's not my job to
categorize what I'm writing
when it's coming out,
because the world is going
to be plenty of that
categorizing.
>> Patrick Rosal: Yep.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
Upon me anyway.
>> Patrick Rosal: Yep.
>> Patricia Lockwood: And
I guess when that's true,
as well when it's a matter
of marketing it's also
a matter of money.
A lot of people who would
consider themselves poets first
and foremost that's like the
phrase I always have it's
like etched on my mind; I
don't know where it came from.
You're not going to
make money that way.
So, yeah you're going to
branch into other fields
and I think it's true.
I think like a genre
is something that flows
out of you as you're writing.
It's like the form
comes out of you.
It's I don't think about whether
I'm writing poetry or prose
when I'm doing the
actual writing,
and since as you mentioned
Twitter and things like that,
on Twitter I'm known as a poet.
So, when people come
to my readings
and they hear me read
anything they call it a poem,
because like they
think that's what I am.
I think that's as
good as anything.
I mean, that makes as
much sense, but yeah,
a huge part of it is that,
you know, like we're not going
to make a ton of
money doing this.
So, we're going to have to
branch out a little bit.
>> Amy Stolls: So, wait.
When you set out to
write, you're not thinking
on what I'm writing,
you're not category; really?
Like you.
>> Patricia Lockwood: You
know what book you're in.
That's what's true of me.
I know what book I'm in, but
even in the midst of something
like [inaudible] I'm writing
something that's essentially
along the poem, so not really.
>> Amy Stolls: It's kind of
fascinating, because you,
you know, there are; I mean we
all know there are differences
for example right?
I mean, like for, you know,
you have we're mostly talking
about creative nonfiction,
prose almost demands you
declaring it true or not
because there are these
categorizations that we've grown
up with, they're fiction,
they're nonfiction, you know,
poetry you have a voice and
there's a little bit more leeway
in there, and of course,
there's; you know,
one of the different things.
>> Camille T. Dungy: Right,
but I think that in poetry
also I have a responsibility
to capital T truth, not facts.
That's not what I'm
talking about.
I'm talking about real
truth; is this believable
to another human heart, right?
And so, how is that different
than truth in nonfiction, right?
So, I think there's
different things
that you're doing with the line.
That often when I start
into writing nonfiction I've
released myself from one
of poetry's great super powers
which is that the line break
at the end you have all these
opportunities for variation,
but there's really
beautiful poetry
that doesn't depend
upon the line either,
so I think sometimes I
know there's an essay
at the very beginning
of "Guidebook
to Relative Strangers" where
I'm at an artist colony
and somebody said like
a ridiculous thing,
and I it was maddening
and rather
than go drink I went
and wrote about it.
And so, that I knew like
I'm angry about this thing
and I'm going to write into
that anger and that writing
into that anger requires
some sort of [inaudible]
of information and history and
context that it's probably going
to be too bulky, right, and so
as I start writing it becomes
and essay and that becomes clear
as I'm writing, but mostly I was
like I am filled with rage
and really practical way
of dissipating that rage
is to get to the page.
And so, I might have written
a poem, right with that.
It's just in this case I
was driving towards a point
at length and that ended up
becoming an essay for me.
>> Patricia Lockwood: There was
that funny [inaudible] a couple
of years ago, where
like the it turned
out The New Yorker was
still fact-checking poems
and there was like a line
in a Michael Robbins'
poem I think it was.
It was like the Swedes invented
refrigeration and they wrote
and they were like "No,
they actually didn't."
And I think that they stopped
after that point, because I know
that I had like some poems
and then after that I'm like,
"Oh those are full of lies."
So, it's good that they're
not doing that anymore.
>> Amy Stolls: So, go with
me here and imagine a world
where we don't have these
categorizations than and how,
so here, you know, did
you; when you came to write
and you know writing and reading
when you were a kid let's say,
did you come through poems
and then come through?
No, so it really is,
you're shaking your head.
>> Patrick Rosal: I didn't.
>> Amy Stolls: Yeah, yeah.
>> Patrick Rosal: I was
kind of a typical product
of American education which is
to say that I was intimidated
by poetry and I thought that it
was completely apart from me.
It was apart from my
family as traditions.
It was literary with a capital
L. It was up there and so, yeah,
poems were not part
of me growing up.
They were part of my entrance
as an adult into loving books,
into you know, really
dedicating my life in terms
of having a formal
relationship with language,
but yeah poetry was not, it
wasn't something that was sort
of engrained in me
very early on.
>> Camille T. Dungy: And I'm
going to say the opposite.
My grandmother was
a school librarian,
an elementary school librarian.
Books were all around and I was
like ecumenical in my reading.
I was just like there
was a book.
It's almost like
Patricia's audiences.
Like it was a book.
I was just reading a book.
It just could be anything
and I trapped through poetry
when I started going in college
and graduate school in poetry,
but even in graduate school
I remember what I was in one
of those programs that
was very, very isolated.
Like you were in the poetry
trap and you weren't allowed
to take any of the fiction traps
and nonfiction wasn't
even a thing
that they were talking
about at that time.
So, the explosion of nonfiction
is a fascinating space for a lot
of us to be writing is,
but that was a trap.
But I was sneaking away
writing stories and working
with the fiction people and
trying to figure out how to,
how to get a kind of
training in prose even
when I was being disallowed
from it because I was a poet
and that was what my
job was supposed to be.
I think when, when my
daughter was born I found
that prose was a way that I can
write because of that training.
That training in poetry
I have been trained
in now what I've come to call
the person from poor lot school
of poetry where like when you
write a poem if anybody knocks
on the door or interrupts
it all the poem is destroyed
and you can't, you know,
then that's why we didn't get
the rest of Kubla Khan, right?
Like, but when you have a
kid like you have the person
from poor lot knocking on
your door every five minutes
and because I think I
was untrained in prose,
I can just keep writing
through it and around it,
because I had already
fiercely figured out how to do
that against all odds
and so it was a wild,
but before my training in my
training in poetry was able
to be overtaken again by
that freedom that I had found
in prose which was
from the leftover
of just you reading something
and you writing it in response.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
Maybe that's why nonfiction
at the moment feels so
elastic too, if it's true
that because I don't have
higher education, I don't know,
but what you're saying
resonates with things I've heard
from other people, if those
traps are so strongly defined
and people want to flee
those a little bit,
maybe they've found this other
ground or this other capacity.
Maybe that is the place
that we've taken those
things, I don't know.
>> Amy Stolls: Patricia
you had said,
wrote I had asked a
question about whether poetry
and prose reaches
different audiences
and you said there's a certain
percentage in my audience
that considers anything I write
in poetry, because I am a poet.
>> Patricia Lockwood: Yeah,
but I think that's why, I mean,
that's okay yeah, right.
It's like it's a matter of
how you get them in the door
and then you can read
whatever you want to them
and they have no control over
it, so again, it's a book.
It's a reading.
You know, what happens in it
is sort of amorphous material
that the form is imposed
upon from without.
>> Amy Stolls: I it's, you're
wrapping my world a little bit
because I have a
lot of questions.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
You ask the questions.
>> Amy Stolls: I know,
because I have questions.
>> Patricia Lockwood: You ask
the questions that interest you.
>> Amy Stolls: Well,
my question is
about how one informs the
other and they'll run,
and where you know, like you
know Camille had said let's
breakdown the walls and that.
You know, we have prose
writers who say don't put me
on a poetry panel
because I can't.
>> Patrick Rosal: Yeah.
>> Amy Stolls: Judge poetry.
>> Camille T. Dungy: Well, I
mean I will say that I think
that as how to train as a poet,
I have an attention to word
like at the word
level and phrase level
and the music level the prose
writers are not necessarily
trained in.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
They're jealous about it too.
>> Camille T. Dungy:
As poets, right?
And so that may be what
one of the differences
between poets writing
prose is that like I found
when I remember like right
after graduate school I tried
to write a novel and
that just didn't work,
because I was writing the novel
and then I would have to break
for the day and I would go
back as I would with a poem
and I would read everything
I've written before
to get the sonic quality.
Well once you hit page 10,
like my whole writing session
was rereading what I had written
the day before and I would
tell that to prose writers
that would be like, it's
not going to work for you.
Like that's crazy.
So, and I didn't do it with the
book of essays all the time,
but there would be
some days and I know
that prose writers do this, so
don't come at me prose writers,
but you don't pay attention
to the words, but I do think
that poets have been trained
usually to pay attention
at the word level, the phoning
level a little bit differently
than how prose writers do
and that, that may be one
of the uniquenesses between
the two of us, right.
>> Patricia Lockwood: I think
it may be even be inherent.
I don't know if it training.
I notice that I get stuck
on words a lot more easily.
I notice that there were
things when I was a kid
that I did not understand
certain idioms that I would pour
over and pour over
because I didn't get them;
jokes I didn't understand.
I still don't get the chicken
butt thing and I never will.
No one can explain it to me.
I had a student who asked me,
she was like sometimes
I read poetry
and I just don't understand
it on a basic sense level.
I was like, if your
body understands it,
you understand it enough.
You have enough of it.
You know what you need to
know and I think to be honest.
>> Camille T. Dungy: For
her that's not enough.
>> Patricia Lockwood: Well, but
I think it was anxiety, yeah,
so what I told her
was that it is enough.
Like if your body is
responding you know something
about this poem that maybe
your head doesn't know yet.
But I think it's true maybe
that we are the people
who misunderstand things,
that we misread things,
that we transpose
words and a lot
of times I'll misread something
and it sounds better to me.
So, I don't know if it's
a thing where, you know,
we're drawn to that training
because it's something
that we already kind of do,
like that might just be me,
but I get stuck on stuff
in a way that is almost
like a childish way and that's
why I pay so much attention
to it, because I have to.
It's just like how I'm wired.
>> Amy Stolls: Why don't
we take, I want to get
into a little bit of the
subject matter that you.
>> Patricia Lockwood: Sure.
>> Amy Stolls: All write about,
but why don't we take a
break and do some reading.
>> Patricia Lockwood: Sure.
>> Amy Stolls: Can you
do; who would like to?
Should we go?
Patrick would you like to read?
>> Patrick Rosal: I don't
know what this is [laughter].
I'm doing work around the race
riots in Watsonville in 1930,
Watsonville, California.
There were Filipino
farmworkers who were dancing
with White women in taxi
dance halls and they,
the White community formed
posses to hunt Filipino's down,
threw them over the
Pajaro River Bridge,
went out to the bunkhouse which
was four miles from downtown
and one of the people from the
posses shot through the wall
into the bunkhouse and killed a
young man named Fermin Tobera.
So, I'm doing a cite, I
didn't even curse yet.
I'm doing a cite-specific
performance.
I hope to do a cite-specific
performance out there
in Watsonville, California.
I'm writing around it.
I'm doing drawings and all
kinds of things The only thing
that you need to know about
this is that I'm an intralocular
with these monomes the
Filipino farmworkers from 1930
and I don't know who's dead.
It's either them or me.
I maybe a ghost visiting
them and one of the things
that they've come
to do over time is
to make kites inside
of this bunkhouse.
"Here is a lie.
The kite maker and his
companions work hard.
They get up under
an orange-blue dawn.
If they dream there's no time
to think about the dreams
of visions of roosters
thrashing deep in the water.
The blade still tied
to their ankles.
The birds aren't drowning,
but they clearly don't belong.
They're kicking their
feet, scratching,
turning in the swirls
of undercurrent.
The men always wake up before
they know if the cocks drown
or grow fins or gills or
get swooped up by nets
and dropped back into a yard
where the animals
make more sense,
into the fields,
hotter and hotter.
Every day, I try to look more
carefully, see more deeply
from all the way out here
this incredible distance.
I'm younger than these
men after all, and yet,
I'm older than them too.
They are as young as
17 and one who looks
like my grandfather barely 23.
Sometimes I get close enough
to them I can ask questions.
When they speak, it's as if
they aren't speaking to me,
but to one another or
a lover left behind.
I can't tell if it's because
they are too far away in time
and miles or if they
just refuse to tell me
about the knife they're holding,
the sound of the blade pulling
through the stalks,
what the ground tastes
like when they have to
suck the blood from the cut
in the thumb they
made themselves
and not lose the
rhythm of reaping.
I don't blame them.
There's nothing to the
work after a while.
There is no thinking.
There was a time when the
men had a deliberateness
and a strangeness to the
bending and cutting and pulling
when they first arrived just
after White men took their names
and asked them if
they could read,
asked if they had
wives back home.
There was a time the men,
these monomes thought
about this comparing
the first lettuce
to the next making sure
they got the whole head.
It doesn't take a
week to stop thinking.
You're body just goes and
your mind does other things.
First it dreams of the
faces it left behind.
How happy they'll be to see you
again to build a house and buy
so many fat pigs
and goats and cows.
You caught me lying again.
They are thinking of sleep or
they are thinking of the uncle
who slapped them on the back
or across their teeth the day
before they left their village,
or they are thinking of
slitting the foreman's neck.
They are thinking of hanging
themselves from a tree.
They are thinking of swimming
in the ocean, the water salt
which is different
from the spicy,
muddy salt of their
own heads and armpits.
They are thinking of swimming
all the way back home.
They are thinking no
will remember their names
when they get back.
They are thinking of
changing their names anyway.
Edison is a good name.
They are thinking of going
back to another province
and finding a wife who will
call them Edison, a famous name
as if a name could
change a face sun bait.
No one weeps anymore.
That's my last lie.
But this man here because he no
longer has to think about how
to grip the handle or the
angle of the knife's edge,
because he is quick with
his work but not too quick.
He can think of something else.
He can think of making kites."
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> Camille T. Dungy: Ii
must say I was to grateful
when Amy invited me to
be part of this panel
because I love these, she
told who was going to be on it
and I love both of these
writers, and so anytime I get
to be in a space with
writers who I really admire;
I've never met you in-person.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
I've never met you.
>> Camille T. Dungy: But, but
I know her work so there we go.
>> Amy Stolls: And
you're all reading poems.
>> Camille T. Dungy: That's
the, I know that's the beauty
of about the beauty
of literature.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
Back around Amy I like it.
Very, very good.
>> Camille T. Dungy:
So, what I'm going
to do is actually read a very
short excerpt from an essay
in "Guidebook to Relative
Strangers" and I'm going
to read a poem from
"Trophic Cascade"
and I chose these two sections
because they were written
within relatively
close proximity
of each other in
time in my life.
And the poem, by the way,
happened to have been written
after a trip home
from Washington,
D.C. when I did some work
with the National
Endowment for the Arts.
So, it seemed like the
right poem to read.
But you can kind of
just hold in mind that,
that these were written within
about a month of each other,
so similar concerns are
spinning through my head.
"In the years before her death,
my maternal grandmother told me
the story of her family's flight
from Shreveport to
Summerville, Louisiana.
My great-grandfather who
owned his own sheet metal shop
in that left behind town who
could read and write and figure
and who understood his worth,
entered his business one morning
and found his young
cousin dead on a worktable.
A note pinned to the body warned
my great-grandfather to get
out of town before nightfall,
but less he be killed as well.
The surviving family piled
into a wagon with nothing
but what the wagon could hold.
'Imagine that', my
grandmother said repeatedly
in the last years of her life.
She didn't talk much about
the new shop or the new town
and the years before
she died it was
that wagon my grandmother
talked about,
loaded with things her family
could haul and that life plucked
from her family's line.
Most Black American
families have a story
of some branch brutally
severed from their family tree.
The only remarkable thing
about my grandmother's story is
that she had to reach
as far back as 1917
to encounter such a trauma.
But pain is an immortal humor,
lasting in a body far
longer than pleasure.
Again, and again my
grandmother asked me
as if I might one visit provide
some satisfactory answer,
what would make a
person do that to a body?
We might be playing with the
baby, grandmother's namesake.
We might be sitting in a nursing
home's courtyard enjoying the
light of the springtime sun.
Once we in a communal
dining room surrounded
by the dying old White Iowans
with whom my grandparents
spent their final years.
She looked around if startled to
find herself amongst strangers
and whispered the story
of her family's flight
as if it were a story
that I that moment
for my very survival
needed to hear.
Grandmother's voice shook
when she recited this story,
not from age, but from the
hard-driven grief that spoke
through muscle to bone,
this must be what they mean
by this role of terror.
My grandmother repeated
her story,
because she could not
help but remember.
She was there.
She walked into the
shop and saw her cousin.
She climbed into the wagon
and rode through the dust.
She felt her father's
fear-born defiance and caution.
She saw her pregnant mother,
several siblings packed up
and driven off before
the last of the light.
She was there you understand
and she had to tell me.
Though, she would likely have
been too young at the time
to remember the incident,
this too is possible.
Hers was the small body
inside her mother's body.
She might not yet have
even been conceived.
This is how history
eclipses all reality.
My grandmother, who could not
help but relive this trauma,
was also as far away
from everything I am
writing as you and as me."
>> Patrick Rosal: Very nice.
>> Camille T. Dungy: Thanks.
[ Applause ]
Thanks. So, that was
the essay excerpt
and then this is a poem called
"Frequently Asked
Questions, Number 7."
Is it difficult to get away from
it all once you've had a child?
I am swaying in the galley,
working to appease this infant
who is not fussing, but will
be fussing if I don't move.
When a black steward
enters the cramped space
at the back of the plane.
He stands by the food
carts prepping his service.
Then he is holding his throat
the way we hold our throats
when we think we
are going to die.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
He is crying.
My God. What they did to us.
I am swaying lest my brown baby
girl make a nuisance of herself,
and the steward is
crying honest man tears.
Seeing you holding your daughter
like that for the first time,
I understand what
they did to us.
All those women sold away from
their babies, he whispers.
I am at a loss now.
Perhaps I could fabricate an
image to represent this agony,
but the steward has walked
into the galley of history.
There is nothing
figurative about us."
[ Applause ]
>> Patricia Lockwood: Since
you so generous Patrick
as to read something that
you do know what it is,
I will do that as well.
I'll read from what I'm
working on right now.
It's just kind of a
hybrid of everything.
It's about an idiot
on the Internet.
"In childhood she had laid
awake at night on fire
with a single question; 'How
did French people know what they
were saying?'
You know, when she
finally asked her mother,
she didn't know either
which meant the problem
must be inherited.
'Can't learn', she
Googled late at night.
Can't learn since
losing my virginity?
Her most secret pleasures
were sentences
that only half the percent of
people on earth would understand
and that no one would be able
to decipher it all in ten years.
Grizzly British witch pits,
sex in the moon next
summer, what is binged?
What is to be corncobbed?
That's the cost of my vegan
lunch, pan [inaudible] my wound.
She could not feel
her first fingertip.
This in the way that your ear
used to get soft pink compliant
and the swirls of hair
around it like damp designs
from talking on the telephone.
A hundred years ago her cat
might have been called 'Mittens'
or 'Pussy willow.'
Now her cat was called
'Dr. Butthole.'
There was no way out of it.
'Dr. Butthole' she called
at night almost in despair
until he trotted to the door
with the bright feathers
of her dignity clinging to
his lips and disappeared
in his alternating
stripes over the threshold.
In Bristol the sunset dripped
as if from a honeycomb.
'This is your contribution
to society?'
a man asked holding up a print
out of her most famous
post, 'Can a dog be twins?'
[ Laughter ]
'Yes', Rachel peeped.
She wanted to explain that she
had also popularized the concept
of today's ceiling wax
manicure where you paint it
over your entire fingertip
in a big careless red blob
and that this had paved
the way for 1776 Corp,
an irony-based esthetic
where people adopted
various visual signifiers
to the founding fathers, but
he had already turned away
in disgust tearing the print up
in two as he went, just as well.
It probably wouldn't be funny
to an Englishman anyway.
But afterward, a boyish figure
stood in line to see her.
He waited until the very end.
'I used to read your
online diary' he confessed
when it was finally his
turn and tears sparked
in her eyes instantaneously.
The diary she had written before
anything had happened to her.
The diary where she used
to make the sort of jokes
that would get people fired now.
'What was your name' she
asked and he told her
and mundane ecstasy began
to rush in her veins.
His had been one of her
very favorite lives.
She remembered it in the
minutest detail, the pine step
to work, the rides back
and forth on the train,
his search for ever spicier
curries, the imagined dimness
of his apartment with
crates of obscure records
and the green waving
gentleness of it all.
She stood up and held him.
She could not help it.
He felt as breakable
as a link in her arms.
It was hard to know
which forms of protest
against the current regime
were actually useful.
The day of the election
her husband had woken
up with a strong urge
to get a face tattoo,
'Either I want a teardrop under
my left eye or I want them
to make my whole skull visible.'
He settled finally on
getting the words 'Stop it'
in very small letters
right near his hairline
where they could
hardly been seen.
When she closed her
eyes she saw people
as polka dots assembling
now into a ballet,
swoop now into a battle, swoop
now as a flock of scavengers
with single word like 'garbage'
saved ever from ugliness
by the swoop the wind,
the uplift in the wings
which were made for this.
A bear breaks into
a Colorado house
and plays the piano
but not very well.
A man with a self-administered
hyena haircut following a woman
through a store and shouting
'Immigrant, immigrant,
immigrant, immigrant.'
In the front seat of
the police car he began
to discuss World War III
and why it would begin.
Why it must begin.
Why it was coming.
Why he would be the general
that led the first charge.
Previously these
communities were imposed along
with their mental weather.
Now we chose them or
believe that we did.
A person might join a site to
look at pictures of her nephew
and five years later
believe in a flat earth.
A man with a chest tattoo
that says 'I can do all things
through Christ who
strengthens me, motherfucker!'
'MySpace was an entire
life' she nearly wept
at a bookstore in Chicago.
And the whole audience
conjured up the image of a man
in a white T-shirt
grinning over his shoulder
and then private music began
to autoplay for each of them.
And it is lost, lost,
lost, lost.
A former presidential
candidate whose face was
as long a cartoon shoe, had
favored a porn in the nights.
It was always thrilling
when this happened.
First there was the
porn itself to dissect,
in this one a red-blooded
American housewife stumbles upon
her stepdaughter getting fucked
from behind by her boyfriend
who seemed likely to
shoot an unbelievable load
of mayonnaise into
her at the end.
Twist though, the woman
in the clip who stood
in a hallway theatrically
pleasuring herself while her
step-daughter was
[inaudible] looking exactly
like the candidate's wife.
This was somehow thrilling
too in its innocence.
He would always desire her, but
at least the blonde substance
that flowed through
her turn sketch.
Rachel though then of the
women of separated twins.
She thought of the
divergence and use
between this identical beauty.
I wanted to end up in a porn
clip slapped up by sexual posts
and how the other had become the
wife of a man who is outspoken
in his belief that people should
not manipulate their genitals.
When the imagination was caught
like this it was no longer
her imagination but the mom's.
Flat architects are awaken
which move through flat scenes
in a cave of the mind.
Torches were raised somewhere
and her blood pounded
and it was the blood of the mom.
She had another heart now
that beat a black shadow
of her real one, but if it
ceased to be, she would die too
like that security robot who
had recently committed suicide
in a fountain face
down insanely funny.
[ Applause ]
>> Amy Stolls: I
was just transport;
I didn't even care whether
it was poetry, right?
Just right?
>> Patricia Lockwood: I'm
trying to imagine what it feels
like being on the Internet.
>> Amy Stolls: There is, I mean
I have encountered your work
and felt and you know through
the page when you are looking
at white space, you
know, or the display
of the words it's a
really different experience
to hear you read it and
the subject and the words
and what you're saying.
It's just and then
categorization kind of,
I'm also right here listening.
I mean, I'm, it's a
really moving experience.
Does it feel different when
you read your, you know,
if you're reading poetry
or reading prose out loud,
to yourself or an audience
versus writing it on the page?
>> Patrick Rosal: I think
when you asked about kinds
of the differences
between poetry and prose,
what's occurring to
me is that poetry
in its tradition maybe closer to
social practices, to gathering,
whereas we think of the novel as
something that you would engage
in just you and the page.
Now, we've taught poetry
as if every poet was
like the archetype of
Emily Dickinson locked
in one's room writing and
then you get, it get arrives
to somebody and the read
it alone in their room.
Poetry is also it's a
social art form, you know,
and it brings people together
certainly for people of color.
It calls back to our family
gatherings, to our social,
to our social gatherings.
And so, maybe there's something
about composing in prose
with this idea of people
actually being in the presence
of one another, of
mourning together,
of celebrating together,
of arguing together,
of dancing together that,
you know, calls up the music
of poetry and of all these
sorts of American traditions.
>> Camille T. Dungy: I think for
me the one thing about reading;
both of the books came
out in the same year
and so I found myself
reading from them
at the same time often, and one
of the things that's very
different is I didn't have
to do a lot of setup
for the poems.
"Frequently Asked
Questions Number 7",
yes those 1 through
10 are in the book,
but you don't really need
to know 1 through 10.
Like I had to come to
terms with the thing
like you don't know
anything else that happened
in that essay body of evidence.
That 5 paragraphs that
I read to is an excerpt
of a huge long other thing
and I wrote an essay partly
for the other rigging that's
around it and then to read it
to you I have to like remove all
that other rigging and get back
to the thing that is that sort
of image kernel right,
about one thing.
And so, that is hugely
different for me coming at,
coming to share prose with you
as opposed to sharing poetry,
is it's the way that it
can just be self-contained;
that a poem can be
self-contained in a way
that an excerpt from an essay
can't be and yet it can be.
What you've got is fine and
it's self-containable and it's,
and it works, it's just you
didn't get a whole bunch
of other stuff and I know that.
So go buy the book and
they you can share it too.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
Yeah, I always felt luckier
as reading poems than, like
you know, the novelist,
comes on after you and
he's like "Alright,
so there's a ballet dancer."
And it's like, I don't have
to do any of that, you know.
I just get up there
and I pop it out.
If feels like you're a little
bit of like the show pony
who comes out and you do a big,
cook but also universal
trick you know?
That it's like it speaks to
the human heart and all that,
but you're like still the pony
and everything and like you get
to see that cool thing.
And you guys there is like you,
there's, there feels like a pop
out quality like a completeness
to it that I always like,
yeah when I read that.
>> Amy Stolls: I guess I was
also thinking of let's writing,
let's move to call it all
writing and when you come
at a subject directly, which
as prose writer it's more,
you know, head on, right,
you're piecing out verses
through a little bit more
slanted, through metaphor,
through you know
working things out
and making a little bit
more; they, you know,
poem sort of invites
the reader to come in
and make different
interpretations like they're
like sometimes prose
doesn't do that as much
because you are saying this on
the page and so when we talk
about there are hard subjects
that we are all, you know,
that your work we're talking
about you know fear and death
and discrimination and misogyny
and hard, hard, hard stuff.
You know, typhoons I was reading
your, but you know, so sometimes
when you approach
this writing do you;
how if you can riff
a little better
about how you approach
sometimes the tough subjects
and whether sometimes it
feels a little easier to do it
through poetry or not,
because of that coming
about it you know what
brings up for you?
>> Patricia Lockwood:
I was telling my escort
when I got here I was like,
I was looking at selections
of what to read today and
I looked at "Priestdaddy"
and I thought if I have to read
about the Catholic Church today,
I will burst into
tears, you know, if I,
if I have to talk
too much about it.
If I have to go through
that, I don't know
if I would be able to do it.
But I, it's also true that
I couldn't have written
about the Catholic
Church in a poem really.
I mean, I could have.
I could have written
about specific moments,
but like if you're
talking about exposing
like institutional abuses,
if it, some things are better
to lay them out in prose
because you can really like;
prose you feel like you
can really slap something
down sometimes, you know?
And it felt that way, but
yeah, I mean it's one thing
to be alone in room
writing these things,
but it's different sometimes
to come out and read them,
you know, when the wounds are
still fresh and when it's not
as if any of the
things we're dealing
with in our work has
stopped happening.
You know, the wounds
reopen every day.
I mean, it's again and again.
So, as you know, we're
reading them, as we're talking
about them, we're
still living them.
>> Camille T. Dungy: Yeah, I
mean I think writing is just a,
it's a difficult thing.
You're writing into
revelation or I am,
I don't know what you are doing.
I am. I am writing into
revelation when I write
and it's always troubling and
disturbing and even when I say
like I knew I was angry about
this thing that this woman said
and I was going to write about
it instead of drink about it,
right, that the essay then still
revealed new things, right,
to me that I didn't; I knew on
the surface why I was so angry,
but spending the time writing
into it I understood a whole
lot more around it or I came to
and that's, that's one of the
scariest things about writing,
but it's also one of the
most, if you see it through,
it's also one of the most
wonderful things about writing.
Is it, that you can really come
to understand not just myself,
but also the world
that has created me
and crated my response
systems and I don't know that,
I don't know that I think
about that differently
in poetry and prose.
I think my subject matters
are, have remained consistent.
I write about family,
I write about history,
I write about the
world, the environment,
the world that I live in.
It doesn't matter what
medium I pick up to do it.
>> Patrick Rosal: Right.
You know, to sort
of riff of Camille,
you write you don't just
write about difficulty.
The music of the language leads
you towards the difficulty,
because often if you're
composing music rather
than I want to say this fact
or convey this information,
you're thinking about the sound
and the contour and the music.
You're not controlling the
"content" of those words.
It's often times that
revelation is difficult.
It's hard.
It's painful.
It's surprising.
It is unwanted and so for
me it's I play a bunch
of musical instruments.
I don't, I don't really
consider myself a singer
and I want all my writing
to sing and the singing
when I'm doing it well really
leads me to something that's,
that's difficult and I'm trying
to be a; I'm trying to learn how
to be a good singer in my
writing in that regard.
>> Amy Stolls: We had
a student this morning
who is our Poetry
Out Loud Program.
He's now a first in college
has won a couple of times
and he talked about writing
a poem in high school right
after he went on a first date.
And he wrote on the first date
and then he wrote this poem,
you know, it was a love poem
and we all kind of gushing,
and then there was only a first
date and then it got published
in his local you know
publication when he wrote it
in October and it got
published in December
and then the girl read it and
came back and said "What?"
And I thought of that
and I thought of this,
our conversation and what you
write and how raw and vulnerable
and you get, you know, in
your writing until you,
and I almost felt like I
just want to say thank you
for getting raw and vulnerable
so that we can get there too.
>> Camille T. Dungy: But you
know, I mean I think part
of that sense of kind of writing
towards it and around it is
that you find more
interesting things.
I have a similar story from my
first book and I have a poem
that it became a; it
becomes a love poem
between my grandparents
in the book and I,
and I like by the time it's in
the book like that's in my mind.
That is a love poem
between my grandparents.
But I went and I read
it at my graduate school
and the guy I had been
dating in graduate school was
in the audience and
I sort of looked up
and I was like, that was to him!
I had completely forgotten
that the poem had become
something much bigger
than that dude, right?
And that's one of the really
great gifts of writing is
that we can come to
knowledge that I was writing
about what love could
be, now what love was
between me and that dude, right?
And so that, then I
can once I reached
into that the poem got
better, the writing gets better
if you untether it from
these little pesty details
like some specific date.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
Who it happened to.
>> Camille T. Dungy:
Yeah, who it happened to.
>> Amy Stolls: Patricia you
had said and I'm just going
to ask maybe one more
question then we'll open it
up for questions
to the audience.
You had, I think there
was something in prestudy
where you had said, I think,
where you had said that you
or feel, you know, feel stronger
on the page then sometimes
in person and it got me thinking
about how, and I'll ask you
because we're all
dealing with this,
if you see yourself here you are
as writing, either, here you are
in poetry and your poems,
here you are in your prose,
here you are in your writing,
but here you are in person
and here you are online too.
And I wonder if you can just
kind of think about you,
or does it you know, again,
riff on how those different
parts are different,
are they not different, are
they deliberately not different
or different and do
you have, you know,
negotiating those spaces?
I mean, I'm looking at you just
because I know you, you know,
but I think we all do because
it's the reality of here we are
in person like you said,
there are certain things
that you don't want to do
in person that you want
to do in your writing.
>> Patricia Lockwood: And it's
because you have, it's not just
because you have more control.
It's also because I was
never the sort of person
who in my life was allowed
to have the arguments
that I wanted to have.
Like when you talked
about, you know,
instead of drinking you
know you're going to go home
and write it out, I mean
there was like a conversation
that could have been had.
I mean, you're going to make
something better out of it
by putting it on the page.
I knew growing up that I
could not had the arguments
with my family and with my
church that I wanted to have.
But I knew that I could
do something on paper
and there's something that
felt very firm about them.
That you had said your say,
and that you then, you know,
and when people talk to
you about it and you're
like here is what I think,
because I'm not always;
I'm a person who tends to
just like open my mouth
and talk a little bit, you
know, but I like to be able
to shape what I talk about more.
I tend not to get
into fights online.
Like I tend not to get mad
online because it's really easy
to say dumb stuff and it's
easy to get drawn into it.
So, I like to be in places
where I have more control
before I talk apart from jokes,
you know, which I probably
make because I am scared
of that stuff, you know.
>> Amy Stolls: I've
been meaning to ask you
about humor with those, yeah.
>> Camille T. Dungy: Yeah.
>> Patrick Rosal: The parts of
being separated are the parts
on the page in our
regular lives.
And you're asking if
I do it or why do it?
>> Amy Stolls: Are
there is, I mean,
do you see this separately?
Or do you really
feel that you do?
>> Patrick Rosal: It's
hard for me to separate.
>> Amy Stolls: Yeah.
>> Patrick Rosal: It's so hard.
I think I was already a kind
of weirdo when I was growing up
and being a writer
has sort of allowed me
to affirm my weirdness.
And so, like the processes
of the ways that I;
the ways that I think when I
write or when I make music,
I carry them into the
world you know when I,
when I interact with people.
I, I remember a conversation
with a colleague;
I used to teach at a small
college, Springfield College
and one of my colleagues Steve
Goldwin stopped me in the street
and we were having
a conversation
about campus politics
or something like that,
and he said, he said, "You
know", Steve's a great guy,
he was like, he's like
"You know, men don't get,
we're not good listeners.
They don't get taught
to be good listeners."
And I was like, "Oh my god,
I'm one of those guys."
And then, Goldwin went on to
say something other things,
but I wasn't listening
so I didn't [laughter].
Writing and being a musician
has created a continuity
between my listening as
a poet and a musician
and my listening in the world.
I'm so grateful that writing
and music and visual art and all
of the dancing has taught me
so many kinds of listening.
Not for the sake of the art
that I make, but for the sake
of the time that I
spend with human beings.
And so that separation
is very difficult for me,
because those perceived
different lives have been
so deeply mutually informative.
>> Camille T. Dungy: Yeah.
I think I would just add to
what Patrick said and something
that Patricia said earlier about
that maybe what's brought her
to writing is just a kind
of quirk of thinking,
is that I been married now for
10 years and I think so living
with him he's like seeing the
me for longer than anybody
but my parents, and he will very
frequently point out the fact
that I just think differently
than people do and it's not
like it's not, he's not saying
it in an antagonistic way
or anything, but it
sometimes it's just like
"Sweetie let me just explain to
you that the way that you got
to that logic point is not the
way that most of us would."
So, can you walk me through it?
No you can't.
You can't, right?
And so, there's like a way that
I think that I get from point A
to point B to 4, you know, like,
like somehow just like do a leap
and that that's, that's a
way that poetry works, right.
It's the way that we understand
poetry to work that we do,
we have sinestesia so we mix,
you know, we mix some sort
of sense with the taste,
with color and things
like that we cross and that
we expect that of poetry,
but I think it's one of the
things that people who think
about poetry and write in
poetry also can bring to prose,
because rather than in an essay,
rather than doing a straight
chronological narrative
of the first year of
my daughter's life,
I'm able to leap around through
time and chronology in a way
that I think is, sorry,
that I think is true
to how we experience time.
Like I actually think
we experience time
in a very unchronological
way, but we're often trained
when we're reading the
who, what, when, where,
why kind of narrative.
We're often trained to read very
linearly, but with the freedom
of a poet's mind, and I
don't know which came first,
the poet's mind or the poet,
right, I'm able to bring
that into prose and so shift
what happens in my essays
and untether them a little
bit from linear narrative
into a kind of, I think,
real-world narrative
but it's really also just
the way I think, right.
That I'm also just
writing as I see the work
and as I communicate the
world and speak it out, right,
and so it's just a like
stylized version of the real me.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
I mean like the joke
about a poet writing a
novel or memoires that will
like describe a leaf for like
20 pages, but they also tell you
when we were born and get
the important facts or things
like that, so when I was talking
about you know like having
to make an argument in
prose things like that,
it was basically painful
for me sometimes to be
like this was the bishop
at the place that I was,
this was the name of this,
this is what happened next,
this is what happened here.
Having to stick some of
that reportage in there was
like difficultly, like
gut-wrenchingly painful for me,
because it's not again
I think you're right,
it's not how I experience
the information.
You know, like I would meet
a person, I would interface
with them, but it's you know
I didn't know their Wikipedia
entries or anything like that.
The things that you
have to put and things
that are not poetry sometimes
are painful for us to put in.
>> Amy Stolls: Yeah, I will
say in preparing for this I had
like an outline and then I
[multiple speakers], let it go.
So, we're not going to go there.
I notice, I don't know
that there are microphones
but I think it would be great.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
You can hear.
Oh, there are microphones.
There's mics.
There are two, two.
>> Amy Stolls: Oh, there are.
Do we have questions?
Would anybody like to ask
these, anyone a if you do would
like to ask a question
you go to the mic.
Thank you, yes.
>> Let's be [multiple
speakers] to the first person.
>> Amy Stolls: There
should be on this side.
>> Where, where does
poetry end and prose begins?
>> Patrick Rosal:
Where does poetry end?
>> Camille T. Dungy:
There's a critic
and poet named James Logenbach
and he has this book called
The Art of the Line or "The Art
of the Poetic Line" I
think from Graywolf Press,
and he has a sentence in that
book that goes something like,
poetry depends; poetry is the
art of thinking in the line.
And prose is the art of
thinking in the sentence,
and prose poetry is what we
invented to make sense of both
of those things, right, and to
refute both of those things.
So, there's this,
three is poetry
that doesn't require the line.
I think there's an easy way
of doing that delineation
and saying all poetry
is lineated
and all prose is unlineated, but
there's really beautiful poetry
that is not lineated and
there's really beautiful prose
that is essentially lineated
because the sentences,
the paragraphs and units
of thought are cut so short
that we read it almost
like lines.
So, in the end, what I'm
telling you is I don't believe
in those lines, right.
I believe that we
are writing towards;
we're writing towards truth,
we're writing towards energy,
and we're writing towards
like a kind of delivery,
the best delivery of
information and there are,
there's an extreme whereby
that's in paragraphs
and chapters and a great link,
and there's another extreme
that it's a single line and
it's crystalized and condensed
and then there's the
children of the marriage
of those two extremes
who are as multi-varied
as the people in this room.
>> Patrick Rosal: I mean,
I was just rereading
Michael Ondaatje's "Running
in the Family" this summer and
he's got conventional chapters
or essays in there and then all
of a sudden you're
reading a poem.
And I guess you would find,
I suppose that you would find
that book in the
Memoire section.
So, for, for Ondaatje even
within one book those
lines are blurred.
I was a DJ for a longtime
and I think about some
of these record stores that
don't have categories for music
and you would find like
Sesame Street next to a record
of MLK speeches, next
to a Sly Stone record
and like an old tango record,
and because there were not
these clear categories,
these things would fire off in
your imagination about kinds
of music that you
could put together
that supposedly don't
belong together.
And so, I think that having
genres is helpful in a way
because it helps
us both as writers
and readers approach the work
with kinds of expectations,
but when we're composing,
I imagine that those
things become less useful
or they're only useful
in that we're trying
to breakdown those
very rigid categories.
>> Patricia Lockwood: I think
if there's one thing the good
poetry; there's one thing
that good poetry has to have
I think a good prose doesn't
necessarily, and I think that
good poetry has to make a leap
through the air of the minds.
I mean you can write a novel
where that doesn't ever happen,
but I think in all good
poems there is a moment
where you just fly and we
know what that moment is,
like you feel it, you feel
something almost like pass
through the ether in your
brain, it's a connection,
but it's like above
the connection.
And you don't necessarily need
to have that in a narrative.
So, I guess that's how I
identify those like kind
of touchy-feeling, but
that's you know, again,
we can identify it
when it happens.
I think everyone knows what
I'm talking about here.
You don't always find
that in a good novel.
You'll probably always
find it in a good poem.
>> Camille T. Dungy:
There was a woman there.
>> Hi. Thank you for being
here in Washington today.
This has been wonderful.
I think that each of your
participates as editors
and editorial work, can you
speak a little bit about how
or whether that informs your own
writing maybe judging as well,
but particularly being
editors or editorial writers
of in other aspects
of your writing life?
>> Patrick Rosal: Yeah.
As a judge and an editor
sometimes I read some revisions
I'm like ah, I wish I did that.
It's a real, it's a real
gift because you know as wild
as I try to make my imagination,
if you're when you're judging a
contest or reading submissions
for a magazine, somebody
always has an idea
that you didn't have before.
And so, you know, it's just a,
it's probably a different part
of engaging my imagination
and I haven't thought;
I've never stolen anything from
anybody, but it certainly fires
up your imagination about
what the possibilities are
and the fact that
your imagination
as one person is really not
quite as good as several
or a multitude of imaginations.
>> Patricia Lockwood:
I'm not really an editor.
I mean, I sometimes
write criticism
but I don't actually do a
whole lot of editorial work,
but I do like writing
criticism because it's
like getting an assignment
that you actually want to do
and I love that aspect of it.
I, like you know getting to
engage on a really deep level
like reading all of someone's
books really drilling down,
that to me feels like if I
could have gone to college
and it had been like that,
I would have liked that.
As it is probably not you know,
probably would not have
done so well otherwise.
>> Camille T. Dungy: I mean
I think it's possible that,
that this thinking that
have about the blurriness
between poetry and prose might
have started to get codified
when I was working on the
"Black Nature" anthology,
each of those poetry sections
was introduced by a prose piece
and many of those prose
pieces are written by people
who identify as poets, honoree
Fanonne Jeffers writes one,
Richard Wright has one and
you think of Richard Wright
as probably as a
prose writer except
for that he has this
incredible collection of haiku
that are just phenomenally
wonderful and so to be able
to have that haiku next to this
excerpt from this wonderful book
which is also so poetic,
"Twelve Million Black Voices."
A lot of the early
African-American writers wrote
in mix genre.
I think Jean Toomer who is
one of the key writers of the
"Harlem Renaissance"
that's like one
of the first American
hybrid text.
Like what is it?
Is it nonfiction?
Is it poetry?
Is it prose?
Like we, I don't know.
And so, just the work of
really spending time with all
of these writers whose
work; who I really admired
and also I resisted,
I resisted a lot
of the typical categorizations
when I put together that book,
so I didn't, I didn't
organize it alphabetically.
I didn't organize
it chronologically.
I organized it based on kind
of the ethos of the poems
and the pieces inside them
and that kind of thinking
about new ways to
categorize and combine
and put things together
made me rethink the way
that I was rigidly assigning my
own text along typical lines.
So, I think it can help you
working through other's work
and curating other's
work and kind
of really helping other
people's work get into the world
in its best light can help you
help me think about my own work
and what potentials it has.
>> Yeah.
>> Hi. As I'm listening to you
I hear you all very poetically
speak of poetry as singing,
listening, conveying truth,
which all sounds like
something a little bit less;
a little bit subconscious,
a little bit less conscious
than our normal conversation.
Do you think that poetry
is a way to convey things
that we feel kind of
behind and beneath or above?
I don't know, but behind
those conventional words
that we normally cannot express?
Like a way of giving vocabulary
to the things that we feel,
whereas, prose is more,
a more conventional way
of talking about ideas?
>> Camille T. Dungy:
Audre Lorde says,
"Poetry is the way we
give name to the nameless
so it can be thought."
So, yeah. But I also
think prose can do it.
It just, the, there are ways in.
There are ways into
understanding ourselves.
>> Patrick Rosal: Yeah.
>> Camille T. Dungy: I
mean, Audre Lorde said
that phrase in an essay.
>> Patrick Rosal: Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
>> Patricia Lockwood: I mean,
people are always
comparing things to poetry,
but when it gets right down to
it we also have to compare it
to something, so we're like
singing sounds good, you know?
Like music is it make sense.
I think that it makes
a lot of sense.
>> Amy Stolls: We have time for
one more question, go ahead.
Yeah.
>> Hi. I'm thinking about
how for poetry so much of it
like shifts when read aloud
versus like [inaudible]
on a page and how so much
of I think as a writer
like reconciling that sort of
tension between how you want it
to look on a page and be
read by an audience member
versus like reading it aloud
and then sort of wondering how
that translates into prose,
which may not have the same sort
of limitations or
in other ways does
and I'm curious what you
guys think about that.
>> Patrick Rosal: There's been
this sort of immense privileging
of the written word over
the, over the spoken word
for a very longtime
in western culture,
and what we really know is the
fact is that the spoken word,
the singing word, the bodies
among bodies making literature
and stories and song
is much, much older
and there's a return to that.
Somebody much smarter than
that coined a phrase called
"The new orality" with the
Internet and performance
and so forth and I know a very
few writers regardless of genre
who are not engaging with their
own work or other people's work
on a stage or without
being out on stage
or on a mic or out loud.
So, this is a whole
other conversation,
because I'm so deeply invested
in the role of performance
in our culture, but I this,
I think that regardless
of genre this out
loud manifestation
of our literature is actually
a central part to the way
that we engage with story
and song in this country.
>> Patricia Lockwood: I
think that it, oh wrap it up.
I think that it can.
>> Amy Stolls: Bring
us home Patricia.
>> Patricia Lockwood: Yes,
so I'll bring us home.
Thank you very much.
When I read my first book
I definitely was in a place
where I didn't have access to
being able to do something,
like you I didn't have a
place where I could perform,
no one wanted to hear
me read my poems.
So, you have in first book,
you have a person at a desk,
you know, writing to herself,
maybe not necessarily
understanding that it going
to be really fucking
hard to pronounce some
of that stuff once you have to
stand up and read it later on.
So, then in my next book
I'm like damn, I get it now.
I know that I'm going to have
to get in front of a microphone
at some point and
read this to people.
So, when it got time to
actually write prose,
I'm like well I know
what I can do.
I can use some of
these little tips
and tricks in prose as well.
Basically, yeah as you're
writing no matter how deep
into it you're getting,
always think
about how it's going to sound.
And read out loud when
you're editing always;
always read out loud and change
the font so that it looks weird
to you and you can
catch mistakes.
>> Amy Stolls: And with
that, we'll it's a wrap.
Thank you too, Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]